I told you earlier this week that the
Tennessee anti-drag bill has been
blocked it does appear to violate the
First Amendment we talked about a new
Gallup study that finds that support for
gay marriage is as high as ever in the
United States the Utah book ban has
backfired and actually led to the Bible
being banned and even the Book of Mormon
is now being looked at to say hey wait a
second if we're Banning sexual and
violent content don't these books also
have to be banned so it has been failure
after failure after failure if we want
to find a silver lining in this entire
cultural war that the right has
Unleashed upon the country it's that
they don't actually seem to have the
majority of the country on their side
and also that they don't seem to have
the law on their side when it comes to
what they're pushing